now I have to tell you why athletes are
early morning system couch potatoes by
definition are people who go to
extraordinary efforts not to sweat right
they make every human effort not to
sweat they're changing the TV channels
honey bring in the popcorn I'm changing
the channels Sun bring me the TV Guide
I'm changing the channels by contrast
athletes have the attitude no pain no
gain and they're out there sweating and
working away power training strength
training running and they sweat athletes
no matter age they sweat more than 5
years and couch potatoes do in 70 years
and when you sweat you don't just sweat
out potassium and Gatorade you sweat out
all 60 essential minerals if you sweat
out all of your selenium and don't
replace it by supplementation you're at
high risk of getting a cardiopathy heart
attack you sweat out all of your copper
and don't replace it by supplementation
you're at high risk of developing an
aneurysm and dying suddenly have a
ruptured aneurysm you sweat out all of
your chromium and vadium and don't
replace by supplementation high risk
getting diabetes and if you sweat out
all of your calcium and magnesium and
Boron and zinc and sulfur and other
minerals are required for cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue bone
you're going to get a joint and Bone
injury what is the biggest single cause
of an athlete's career being ended early
joint and Bone problems right and that's
because they sweat out all the basic
minerals that they need to maintain
those parts of their body and they don't
supplement with them because doctors
tell them that they can get everything
they need by eating their four food
groups well what are the early warning
systems for for mineral deficiencies we
already told you about white gray or
silver hair for a copper deficiency
liver spots are age spots in the back of
your hand side of your face or neck
these things are caused by a selenium
deficiency and you know again about
selenium deficiency then of course you
have toe cramps leg cramps so you can
have hypertension these things are all
caused by a deficiency of calcium and if
you're an athlete at age 25 or 15 and
you get a leg cramp that's a Calcium
deficiency your body's telling you if
you don't stop drinking those Pepsis and
start supplementing with some calcium by
the time you're 40 50 60 years old
you're going to have arthritis and
osteoporosis but most people say wow I
got to get this high price trainer I
need somebody who can give me massage
therapy because I have a cramp and they
don't go and take their supplements